THE WEIRDEST NIGHT IN MEMORY.
WE ARE BACK TOMORROW.
>> SEAN: WE START WITH A FOX
NEWS ALERT, TODAY WE ARE ONLY
320 DAYS AWAY FROM THE ELECTION
OF 2020, WHEN YOU GET TO DECIDE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN HELL-BENT O
RIPPING THIS COUNTRY APART FOR
THREE STRAIGHT YEARS.
THREE YOUNG EARS OF HATE AGAINS
THE PRESIDENT COUPLED WITH THEI
INABILITY TO ACCEPT THE OUTCOME
OF WE THE PEOPLE IN THE 2016
ELECTION HAS NOW RESULTED IN ON
OF THE MOST, IF NOT THE MOST
PATHETIC DISGUSTING REPULSIVE
AND FRANKLY DANGEROUS POLITICAL
STUNTS IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
IT'S BEEN HAPPENING ALL DAY AND
NIGHT, THIS ENTIRE SHOW HAS NOW
COME TO LIGHT.
IT IS NOTHING BUT A REVOLTING
CHARADE BASED ON NOTHING, EXCEP
THEY HATE LOSING AND THEIR SORE
LOSERS.
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING, WHAT
THEY BEEN UP TO 43 YOUNG LIRA
YEARS HAS BEEN HURTING THIS
COUNTRY.
IT'S HURTING OUR COUNTRY TONIGHT
.
DEMOCRATS COULD CARE LESS.
AT THIS HOUR THEY ARE ALL
JUMPING FOR JOY, WHILE THEY'VE
BEEN PRETENDING TO BE SOLEMN AN
SOBER AND SOMBER AND WHATEVER.
EVEN THAT IS ALIVE.
LET'S LIE LIKE WE ALWAYS DO,
LET'S SAY WE DID THIS
PRAYERFULLY, BUT PAINFULLY.
ALL THESE PEOPLE HAVE DONE FOR
THREE YEARS IS LIVE.
THE SAME WITH THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA MOB.
HOUSE LEADERSHIP HAD TO ASK
THEIR MEMBERS NOT TO PERFORM
THEIR VICTORY DANCE IN PUBLIC
VERY INSTEAD THEY WERE
INSTRUCTED TO ACT IS SOMBER, NO
HIGH-FIVING.
IT'S A PRETTY TALL ORDER FOR
SOME AS DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
DREAMING OF THIS MOMENT FOR
THREE PLUS YEARS.
IT HAS BEEN IN THE WORKS SINCE
BEFORE DONALD TRUMP WAS EVEN TH
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE.
LET'S GO TO POLITICAL APRIL 26
OF 2016.
COULD TRUMP BE IMPEACHED SHORTL
AFTER HE TAKES OFFICE?
IMPEACHMENT IS ALREADY ON THE
LIPS OF MANY.
ONE OF THOSE MEMBERS OF CONGRES
WAS YES, JERRY NADLER HIMSELF.
HE CHAIRED THE DEMOCRATS ONE
WEEK, IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING,
IVORY TOWER PROFESSORS ONE OF
WHICH WANTED TO IMPEACH TRUMP
FOR TWEETING OUT THE WORDS FAKE
NEWS.
IN NOVEMBER OF 2016, HE
EXPLAINED, WE CAN'T WAIT FOR
YEARS TO VOTE MR. TRUMP OUT OF
OFFICE SO WE MUST DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN DO TO STOP TRUMP AND HIS
EXTREME AGENDA.
THAT WAS NOVEMBER 20, 2016.
A FEW MONTHS LATER JANUARY 20
th, 2179 MONTHS
AFTER HE WAS SWORN INTO OFFICE,
THERE IS THE WASHINGTON POST
DECLARING THE CAMPAIGN TO
IMPEACH TRUMP HAS BEGUN.
COMMIT WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE.
HILLARY CLINTON WAS NONE ONLY
DISTRICTWIDE THE DEMOCRATS, THE
MEDIA MOB, THEY NEVER SAW THIS
COMING.
THE SORE LOSERS, THEY HAVE BEEN
PLOTTING THEIR REVENGE EVER
SINCE, EVEN BEFORE.
FIRST IT WAS RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, CONCLUSION, COLLUSION,
COLLUSION.
OBSTRUCTION, TAXES, AND THEN IT
WAS CAMPAIGN VIOLATIONS.
THEN BACK TO RUSSIA.
NOW THE UKRAINE.
THEY COOKED UP WHAT ARE
ABSOLUTELY MEANINGLESS CHARGES
FEATURING ZERO EVIDENCE.
ONE FACT WITNESS, THE REST WAS
HEARSAY.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
NO QUID PRO QUO, UNLIKE JOE.
LOOK AT JOE.
IN ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING IN LESS YOU
FIRE THE GUY INVESTIGATING MY
SON WHO HAS ZERO EXPERIENCE
MAKING MILLIONS.
YES, THE VERY THING THEY SAY
THEY'RE OUTRAGED ABOUT.
NOW, THEY'RE ALL INTERESTED IN
ABUSE OF POWER AND THEY HAVE TO
LOOK IN THE MIRROR BECAUSE THE
SHOW IN AND CONGRESS WE'VE BEEN
WITNESSING ALL DAY, THERE IS
REAL ABUSE OF POWER AND IT IS
THEM.
LET'S MAKE ONE THING CLEAR
TONIGHT, THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THIS IS ABOUT
YES, YOU, WE, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE EURIPIDES WILL BOLD
DEPLORABLE'S THAT CLING TO OUR
GOD AND OUR CONSTITUTION AND OU
BIBLES.
THE DEMOCRATS THINK WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE REALLY DUMB.
THEY THINK THEY KNOW BETTER.
THEY CLEARLY LOOKED DOWN ON US.
THEY DETEST OUR WAY OF LIFE AND
THEY DON'T LIKE OUR POLITICS,
RELIGION, OUR CHOICES, OR OUR
CANDIDATES AND THE WAY WE VOTE.
THEY BELIEVE EVERYBODY ON THIS
MAP SHOULD BE RULED BY LAWMAKER
IN NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA, SAN
FRANCISCO, LA, NEW JERSEY, NEW
YORK.
THAT'S NOT HOW OUR SYSTEM WORKS.
WE ARE PROTECTED FROM THIS
PURRING OF FAR LEFT RADICALS
STATE -ISM AND IMPERIALISM.
THEN THE WILL OF WE, YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL PREVAIL.
YOU WILL HAVE ALL THE POWER IN
320 DAYS.
WHAT WE'VE BEEN WITNESSING ALL
DAY AND ALL NIGHT, IS NOTHING,
BUT POLITICAL THEATER.
I HAVE GOOD NEWS.
ALL OF IT IS HELPING THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
REELECTION OF DONALD TRUMP.
A BRAND-NEW POLL, THE PRESIDENT
'S APPROVAL RATING IS
UP AND SUPPORT FOR IMPEACHMENT
IS DOWN DRAMATICALLY.
LEASE UP SIX POINTS SINCE THE
SHOW STARTED.
MEANWHILE IN THE USA TODAY WILL
HAS THE PRESIDENT BEATING EVERY
SINGLE POTENTIAL DEMOCRATIC
RIVAL.
AMERICANS KNOW A POLITICAL SHAM
AND A WITCHHUNT WHEN THEY SEE I
FOR THREE STRAIGHT YEARS.
AS PER USUAL, THE PRESIDENT IS
FIGHTING BACK.
YOU SEE THAT RALLY?
EARLIER TONIGHT, THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE PACKED INTO AN ARENA.
THE GREATEST POLITICAL SHOW ON
EARTH.
THEY COULDN'T GIVE A FLYING RIP
ABOUT THESE PEOPLE HELL-BENT ON
DESTROYING.
CAN YOU NAME IN YOUR OWN MIND,
ONE THING THAT THEY HAVE DONE T
HELP THIS COUNTRY, TO HELP THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN?
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STEMS.
LUIS LABOR PARTICIPATION RATE
SINCE THE 70s.
TRUMP, 7 MILLION FEWER PEOPLE
UNFREEZE DAMS.
7 MILLION MORE JOBS.
THE BEST EMPLOYMENT SITUATION
SINCE 1969.
WHAT HAVE THE DEMOCRATS DONE?
CAN YOU THINK OF ONE THING
EXCEPT PAINTING FROM?
WE ARE 320 DAYS AND YOU GET THE
POWER.
DEMOCRATS PROBABLY KNOW DEEP IN
THEIR HEARTS THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO DO WELL.
IT IS RADICAL EXTREME SOCIALIST
AGENDA.
HE BRAGS ABOUT IT, ZERO
EXPERIENCE, PAID MILLIONS.
LEVERAGING TAX DOLLARS.
THE DEMOCRATS IGNORE IT.
THAT'S HOW HYPOCRITICAL THEY AL
ARE.
BY THE WAY, IN THE CASE OF QUID
PRO QUO, JOE COULD BARELY STRIN
TWO SENTENCES TOGETHER WITHOUT
GETTING CONFUSED.
ELIZABETH WARREN, A DISHONEST,
HONEST HER ENTIRE CAREER,  BUT
SHE FAKED HER OWN RACE FOR
DECADES THEN YOU HAVE THE ANGRY
SOCIALIST COMMUNIST BERNIE
SANDERS.
HE WANTS US TO LOOK LIKE
VENEZUELA.
THEN YOU HAVE ME REPEAT, IT'S
PRETTY OBVIOUS THIS IMPEACHMENT
CHARADE IS NOT ABOUT REVENGE,
IT'S A DESPERATE POLITICAL PLOY
IT IS A POWER GRAB.
DEMOCRAT AL GREEN, CONGRESSMAN
SAID IF WE DON'T IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, HE'LL GET REELECTED.
AOC SAYING THIS IS ABOUT
PREVENTING THE DISASTROUS
OUTCOME FROM OCCURRING NEXT YEAR
.
JUST TODAY, THE CORRUPT
COMPROMISE COWHER CONGENITAL
LIAR, THE MAN HIMSELF, ADAM
SCHIFF ECHOED THOSE CONCERNS.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE CLEAR
THAT HE IS NOT GOING TO STOP
SEEKING FOR AN INTERVENTION AND
ELECTION PARADE HE'S ON THE
WHITE HOUSE LAWN SAYING IF A BE
HONEST THERE'S A SIMPLE ANSWER,
I WANT UKRAINE TO DO THIS IT.
>> THE TIMING IS DRIVEN BY THE
URGENCY.
>> A NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE, A
ISSUE OF OUR ELECTION INTEGRITY.
THAT IS NOT A REMEDY FOR THE
MISCONDUCT.
>> OH WILL GIVE YOU A FULL HOUR.
OF FOUR HOUR.
COME, SIT, TALK.
HE IS WORRIED ABOUT LOSING AGAI
AND 2020.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE IS EVER
PART OF IT IS A DISGUSTING
PATTERN THAT HAS NOW GONE ON
THREE STRAIGHT YEARS.
DEMOCRATS ARE ALWAYS LOOKING FO
WAYS TO RIG THE SYSTEM.
THEY HAVE USED THE IRS TO TARGE
CONSERVATIVE AND TEA PARTY
GROUPS.
THE USE THE FBI WE NOW KNOW IT'
ALL CONFIRMED, EVERYTHING WE
TOLD YOU FOR ALMOST THREE YEARS
TO SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
TRANSITION AND DEEP INTO THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
THEY CALLED FOR ELECTORAL
COLLEGE TO BE ABOLISHED.
THEY WANT TO STACK THE COURTS I
A SCHEME TO MANIPULATE THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT SO THEY CAN
LEGISLATE FROM THEIR.
NOW THEY'RE USING THE VERY
SERIOUS TOOL OF IMPEACHMENT
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO ALTER THE
OUTCOME OF AN UPCOMING ELECTION.
MEANWHILE THE PRESIDENT
ACCOMPLISHMENT AFTER
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
WE CAN GO ON.
THE WASHINGTON EXAMINER PUT A
COUPLE HUNDRED UP THERE IF YOU
WANT TO READ THEM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN BUSY
DESPITE THE MOST DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES OUT THERE KEEPING
HIS PROMISES.
HE'S WORKING TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF AMERICANS MAKE US MORE
PROSPEROUS, TRY TO MAKE US MORE
SAFE AND MORE SECURE AND KEEPIN
HIS WORD.
TAX-CUT ENDING.
ENERGY INDEPENDENT, NEXT
EXPORTER OF ENERGY FOR THE FIRS
TIME IN 75 YEARS.
HE PROMISED FAIR TRADE DEALS
PARADE WE GOT IT.
PRISON REFORM, DONE.
THE RIGHT TO TRY, AND THAT'S
DONE BY THE PRESIDENT.
IF YOU WANT TO TRY SOMETHING,
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO IT.
BUILDING THE WALL ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, HE'S GETTING
THAT DONE TO.
TAKING OFF THE RIDICULOUS
HANDCUFF RULES OF ENGAGEMENT
FROM THE OBAMA ERA, DONE.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
LOOK AT OUR ECONOMY.
ONE RECORD AFTER ANOTHER THAT I
NOW BEING SET IN THIS COUNTRY.
NO POLITICAL STUNT IS GOING TO
SLOW DOWN THE PRESIDENT'S AGEND
AGENDA.